mais la république vive la france
enfin je voulais dire bonjour à tous et
bienvenue sur votre chaîne de
vulgarisation politique
la chaîne qui vous explique
l'organisation politique française en
quelques minutes
comme vous l'avez deviné aujourd'hui on
va parler de la république la république
on en parle beaucoup on entend beaucoup
parler mais au final bien que 150 pays
dans le monde se disent être des
républiques c'est parfois difficile de
vraiment comprendre ce que ça veut dire
déjà le mot république vient du latin
respublica qui veut dire chose publique
ça signifie que gouverner la cité est
une affaire publique et collective pas
une chose privée
il est impossible de donner une seule
définition de la république car son sens
et ses réalités ont beaucoup évolué au
cours de l'histoire
et selon les pays mais on peut quand
même essayer de réunir les états
républicains autour de trois
caractéristiques
premièrement le poste de chef de l'état
n'est pas héréditaire
contrairement à une monarchie ou un
empire une république est un état où la
puissance publique est soumise à la loi
ce qu'on appelle un état de droit enfin
une république agit pour l'intérêt du
peuple au sein de laquelle il est
souverain
malgré ça tous les états républicains ne
sont pas les mêmes il existe par exemple
des république unitaire comme la france
ou l'italie
il existe aussi des république fédérale
comme l'allemagne ou les états unis
enfin il ya aussi des fédérations d'état
comme la suisse ou la russie certains
pays utilisent aussi un qualificatif
pour compléter le mot république
on peut par exemple citer la république
populaire de chine la république
populaire démocratique de corée
la république islamique d'iran la
république socialiste du vietnam la
république soviétique pour le rss ce
type de qualificatifs sert souvent à
limiter l'aspect républicain du pays
parce que si certains pays sont des
républiques indiscutables comme les
états unis l'allemagne ou la france
car il possède bien les trois
ingrédients qui font d'eux une
république
d'autres sont parfois considérés comme
étant moins républicain ou pas
républicain du tout par exemple si on
prend l'iran
c'est une république islamique car la
moitié de l'organisation de son pays
répond un système républicain
l'autre moitié répond plutôt un système
théocratique où les citoyens ne sont pas
simplement égaux face à la loi de la
république mais aussi face à la loi de
dieu
d'autres comme le vietnam ou la chine
sont des républiques socialistes ou
populaires respectant certains aspects
de la république mais sont souvent
considérés comme des dictatures depuis
l'extérieur car entre autres la gestion
du pays ne se fait que par le prisme
d'un seul parti le parti communiste
on peut aussi citer la corée du nord qui
se dit être une république populaire
démocratique mais qui se sert surtout de
ces trois mots pour véhiculer une
certaine propagande pour certains pays
en effet être une république sert à
faire croire à une recherche du bien
commun en leur sein et à dissimuler une
dictature
d'ailleurs l'une des questions qui
revient souvent lorsqu'on cherche à
définir la république et quelle est la
différence entre la république et la
démocratie et c'est vrai que si on
regarde étymologiquement les deux termes
sont finalement assez proches
res publica étant la chose publique et
des mauves kratos est dans le pouvoir du
peuple
dire qu'un état est une république ne
suffit pas à faire de celui-ci une
démocratie on peut par exemple parler
encore une fois de la chine qui se dit
être une république mais qui n'est pas
une démocratie comme on le verrait en
france
al'inverse certains pays ne sont pas des
républiques mais sont quand même des
démocraties comme le japon ou le royaume
uni
on pourrait presque appeler ces
monarchies parlementaires dont le roi où
l'empereur lac un pouvoir symbolique et
qui ont un fonctionnement très proche
des républiques des républiques
monarchiques
la grande différence entre la démocratie
et la république et que la démocratie
met en avant l'individu et ses
particularités pour composer la société
al'inverse la république considère
l'intérêt commun avant l'individu et ses
particularités
en bref pour la démocratie le bien de
chacun et le bien de tous alors que pour
la république c'est le bien de tous
qui est le bien de chacun bien sûr dans
la pratique les deux notions ne sont pas
contradictoires
et c'est pourquoi de nombreuses
république sont aussi des démocraties
ces républiques démocratiques font le
pari de la mise en avant de l'intérêt
général mais sans étouffer les intérêts
particuliers
laissons alors la diversité culturelle
protéger et garanties s'exprimer dans la
sphère publique
bon maintenant qu'on a un peu mieux
compris ce qu'est une république
regardons d'un peu plus près la
république française aujourd'hui en
france on est très attaché à la
république mais il ne faut pas oublier
que son installation a été difficile et
très contestée avant la révolution de
le roi était louis saez et le régime
français était la monarchie absolue de
droit divin lors de la révolution
française
l'objectif du peuple n'était pas de
mettre en place une république mais
d'abolir les privilèges de la noblesse
et de l'église afin de créer une société
plus égalitaire
c'est d'ailleurs à cette époque qui est
écrite
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen à l'époque on voulait passer
d'une monarchie absolue avec tous les
pouvoirs au roi à une monarchie
parlementaire sur le modèle de
l'angleterre avec des contre pouvoirs
pour limiter le roi
le truc ce que louis saez n'avait pas du
tout envie de partager son pouvoir et en
1792 il fuit paris pour essayer de
rejoindre l'étranger afin d'organiser
une contre révolution mais il est arrêté
à varennes
à ce moment là on se dit que garder un
roi qui trahi la révolution et la nation
c'est peut-être pas une bonne chose
et alors on proclame la première
république mais c'est pas parce que la
république est proclamé que tout va bien
car à ce moment là tout est encore très
expérimentale et chaotique
la première république ne dure que 12
ans et pourtant elle est déjà divisé en
trois parties la convention nationale
qui verra la décapitation de louis saez
et la terreur le directoire qui se
finira par le coup d'état du 18 brumaire
de napoléon et enfin le consulat qui lui
verra même la fin de la 1ère république
et l'avènement du premier empire en 1804
s'en suit alors plusieurs décennies ce
sens république avec donc le premier
empire avec napoléon puis le retour de
la monarchie qu'on appelle la
restauration avec comme roy les deux
frères de louis saez louis xviii puis
charles 10 même avec la révolution des
trois glorieuses on garde la monarchie
avec cette fois-ci louis-philippe comme
roi des français
ce n'est qu'en 1848 après 44 ans en
république qui éclatent encore une
révolution qui cette fois ci se fera
presque sans effusion de sang et
laissera place à la deuxième république
dans l'année louis napoléon bonaparte le
neveu de napoléon sera élu premier
président de la république française
mais un bonaparte reste un bonaparte et
le petit louis napoléon décide en 1851
de faire un coup d'état
et de mettre en place le second empire
dès 1852
bien que la deuxième république était
est courte elle est importante dans les
mémoires de la république française elle
a montré qu'une révolution pouvait se
faire presque 120 200 et que la
république ne signifiait pas la terreur
c'est la république qui aura mis fin
définitivement à l' esclavage et qui
aura tenté la première le suffrage
universel
même s'il est encore que masculin le
suffrage universel est un acte fort car
il montre que les révolutions ne sont
plus nécessaires et que les citoyens
peuvent changer les choses
eux mêmes avec leur vote en 1870
s'achève le second empire avec la
défaite de napoléon iii à sedan et la
perte de l'alsace lorraine au profit de
l'allemagne à ce moment là se pose une
question quel régime pour succéder au
second empire
mais la deuxième république or à semer
les graines républicaine qui germeront
pour la troisième c'est ainsi que la
troisième république est proclamée au
départ fébrile ce sera jusqu'à présent
la république la plus longue de
l'histoire et laissera comme empruntent
la liberté d'expression la laïcité
l'éducation des masses et infor
patriotisme républicain c'est la
république qui connaîtra la première
guerre mondiale et qui s'arrêtera avec
la deuxième durant la deuxième guerre
mondiale
pétain mettra en place l'état français
qui n'est pas une république ni une
monarchie à la fin de la guerre le
gouvernement provisoire de la république
mettre en place la quatrième république
qui posera les bases d'une france
sociale on conservera d'ailleurs le
préambule de la constitution de la
quatrième république qui décrit des
valeurs telles que la liberté de la
presse
la protection à la santé l'égalité homme
femme pour l'incorporer à la
constitution de la vème république
mais la quatrième république souffre
d'un grand défaut son instabilité
gouvernementale
et c'est cette instabilité qui poussera
le général de gaulle à mettre en place
la cinquième république dans laquelle
nous vivons actuellement la 5ème
république n'est pas sans défauts bien
sûr mais elle semble assez solide et
stable pour avoir su s'adapter aux
nombreux changements du monde depuis
au final si on regarde l'évolution de la
france du xviiie siècle à aujourd'hui on
peut voir que la république a mis du
temps à s'imposer et qu'elle a dû au fil
du temps faire face aux monarchies aux
empires ou encore plus récemment au
régime de vichy et c'est tout au long de
cette longue histoire que la république
française a su définir des valeurs et
des principes qui la caractérise ces
principes
on les retrouve principalement dans le
préambule et l'article premier de la
constitution de notre république actuel
tout d'abord la république est attachée
aux droits de l'homme et aux principes
de souveraineté nationale avec un
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple et
pour le peuple
elle est aussi attachée aux droits et
devoirs de la charte de l'environnement
qui définit par exemple que toute
personne a le devoir de prendre part à
la préservation et à l'amélioration de
l'environnement
bien sûr on retrouve parmi les principes
fondamentaux de la république française
la liberté l'égalité et la fraternité
le triptyque qui est aussi sa devise la
république française est indivisible
mais décentralisée laïque démocratique
et sociale
elle assure l'égalité devant la loi de
tous les citoyens sans distinction
d'origine de race ou de religion
elle respecte toutes les croyances ses
valeurs et principes sont des objectifs
jamais vraiment atteint mais que la
république se donne pour but de réaliser
ou de défendre
voilà maintenant vous savez tout sur la
république ce que ça veut dire
en france et ailleurs cette vidéo est
donc terminée si elle vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu et
un commentaire vous pouvez nous
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux
facebook et twitter
merci à vous et à très bientôt